le sens est ouverte
mes chers collègues l'audition à
laquelle nous procédons est en consacré
à une personnalité appartenant à sa
famille politique le président de la
commission d'enquête a demandé à se
déporter c'est pourquoi j'ai l'honneur
de présider cette séance
nous recevons donc aujourd'hui Monsieur
Philippe Olivier député européen
c'est le député cher collègue je vous
remercie d'avoir répondu à notre
convocation dans les délais très bref
comme vous le savez notre commission de
travail depuis plusieurs mois sur les
ingérences de puissance étrangères dans
la vie politique économique et auprès
des relais d'opinion de notre pays
souhaiterons ce titre recueillir votre
témoignage concernant les relations que
vous entretenez avec la Russie
mais bien sûr non bien sûr pour vous les
reprocher mais pour établir si vous avez
pu être le vecteur d'opération
d'ingérence de la part de ce pays dans
la vie politique nationale
nous interrogerons en particulier sur
les voyages que vous avez pu faire en
Russie et dans les Territoires
Ukrainiens occupés illégalement par la
Russie nous interrogerons également sur
vos relations avec des personnalités
russes proches du régime de Vladimir
Poutine parmi lesquels l'oligarque
Constantin
cette audition je le précise et
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale il enregistrement
vidéo sera ensuite disponible à la
demande je vous laisserai la parole pour
une intervention luminaire d'une dizaine
de minutes puis nous poursuivrons nos
échanges sous la forme de question et de
réponse
auparavant je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires imposent
aux personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
le serment et de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je vous invite
donc à lever la main droite et à dire je
le jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
appuyez à droite
ah d'accord merci écoutez très
honnêtement je n'ai aucun lien avec la
Russie
vous surprendre peut-être parce que vous
attendiez à ce que à ce que j'en ai je
n'en ai pas j'ai fait deux voyages en
Russie dans toute ma vie j'ai fait un
voyage à l'occasion de la Coupe du monde
du football en 2018 et j'ai fait un
voyage de contrôle d'élection on va dire
ça comme ça dans le cadre de mon mandat
parlementaire un voyage qui a été
déclaré très de manière tout à fait
transparente sur le site de du Parlement
européen et qui est d'ailleurs sur le
site sur mon site personnel et donc tout
ça est tout à fait légal en ce qui
concerne le premier voyage qui était en
2018 en 2018 je ne suis pas élu je suis
un simple citoyen
je suis sport à l'invitation d'un ami
français qui est installé depuis
longtemps qui n'a mis de 20 ans qui me
dit viens voir il y a Coupe du monde
donc voilà et c'est l'occasion de
rencontrer des gens mais vraiment très
subtilement et avant je n'ai aucun
contact avec eux après je n'ai aucun
contact avec eux je n'ai aucun contact
je n'ai jamais mis les pieds ambassade
de Russie je n'ai aucun contact avec des
Russes donc je ne sais pas bien ce que
j'ai d'autres à vous dire en ce qui
concerne mes liens avec la Russie
très bien
moi j'avais quelques questions à vous
poser en préalable de des questions de
madame le rapporteur et des autres
commissaires présents
le 27 octobre 2022 France 2 a diffusé un
numéro du magazine complément d'enquête
consacré au réseau Poutine en France
vous êtes présenté comment entretenant
des liens importants avec la Russie
contrairement à ce que vous venez nous
dire comment vous réagir à ces
diffusions
pour être très honnête je n'ai même pas
regardé le reportage car ça n'a
strictement aucun intérêt je sais très
bien les liens que j'ai ou plutôt que je
n'ai pas avec la Russie et je pense
qu'on est dans un sort de délire
complotiste qui voudrait qu'on ait des
liens avec la Russie je n'ai aucun lien
avec la Russie
et c'est pas pas excusez-moi mais c'est
pas parce que c'est affirmé par un
journaliste que c'est vrai il n'y a
aucun fait qui était avec cela je vous
ai dit les deux voyages que j'ai fait en
Russie
mon histoire avec la Russie s'arrête là
ok toujours dans cette perspective vous
êtes allé en Crimée pourquoi êtes-vous
allé en Crimée occupée en juillet 2020
j'imagine qu'il n'y avait pas de lien
avec la Russie qui a pris ce
l'initiative de ce séjour et comment
a-t-il été financé alors nous y avons
été avec une groupe un groupe de cinq ou
si députés nous avons été invités par le
fédération civique pour aller voir les
élections c'était un référendum sur
constitutionnel qui était organisée à
cette occasion
j'ai eu la possibilité d'aller en Crimée
et je me suis rendu en Crimée pourquoi
je me suis rendu imprimé c'est pas une
position politique c'était simplement
parce que comme parlementaire je veux
aller sur place vous expliquer que c'est
un
région occupée et je voulais voir si
c'était vraiment occupé très honnêtement
je n'ai pas vu que c'était une région
occupée c'est une région qui est
totalement russe et voilà j'ai été en
observation d'un parlementaire libre qui
va qui va faire son travail pour se
faire une opinion par lui-même comme je
vous l'ai dit ce voyage a été déclaré
tout à fait légalement au Parlement
européen et sur le site internet du
Parlement européen accessible non
seulement au Parlement européen non
seulement à vous-même mais à tous les
citoyens de France
merci monsieur le député une dernière
question avant de laisser la parole à
Madame la rapporteur je reprendrai la
parole à la fin n'avez-vous des liens
avec l'association dialogues franco-rus
qu'au président
absolument aucun
je n'ai jamais mis les pieds
dans une quelconque réunion du dialogue
francourus
je suis très ami avec Thierry Mariani
qui à mon collègue au Parlement européen
mais je n'ai aucun lien avec le dialogue
franco-russe
merci de votre réponse madame
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député européen nous avons bien entendu
que vous
minimisez permettez-moi l'emploi de ce
verbe
[Musique]
les relations qui vous sont prêtés par
un sombre d'organes de médias ou ou des
fondations
champignons sur rue avec avec la Russie
moi je voulais revenir quand même sur ce
que vous avez vous-même
confirmer à l'instant à savoir que vous
étiez rendu effectivement en 2018 à
l'occasion de la finale de la Coupe du
monde de football en Moscou et invité
par un ami français
dites-vous et
visite à Moscou au cours de laquelle
vous avez rencontré
Constantin Malo fief que vous ne
connaissiez peut-être pas avant en tout
cas c'est ce que vous vous dites dont
acte il se trouve alors est-ce que vous
nier la véracité de ces documents mais
que la Fondation
dossier Center qui a produit un sombre
de d'éléments de production de de mails
par exemple et les a rendus public à
travers notamment
des journalistes qui ont réalisé
l'émission
un complément d'enquête pour complément
d'enquête dont il a fait état
certains de ces éléments produits par
l'ONG basée à Londres dossier Center
font état d'un courriel que vous avez
écrit que vous auriez écrit
après votre venue à Moscou pour assister
à cette finale et dans laquelle c'est en
quelque sorte un courriel lettre du
château si je puis dire pour remercier
de l'accueil que vous envoyez à un
certain Michael mais dans laquelle
courriel dans lequel vous faites
également allusion à la rencontre et à
la teneur de la rencontre avec Monsieur
Constantin Malo fief semblerait-il
puisque vous écrivez encore une fois
peut-être allez-vous le nier ou le
minimiser mais si j'en crois de ces
Center vous écrivez je cite j'ouvre les
guillemets
et c'est à votre signature les belles
rencontres que nous avons pu faire grâce
à vous seront utilité
pardon décisive pour les prochaines
élections européennes nous allons
maintenant travailler de notre côté à
leur donner tous les développements dont
la cause a besoin je ferme les
guillemets pouvez-vous devant cette
commission d'enquête nous en dire un peu
plus sur ce que vous avez écrit à savoir
l'utilité décisive pour les prochaines
élections européennes ou les
développements dont la cause a besoin
s'agissant d'une rencontre avec
Constantin Malo fief
je vais vous préciser ça sans problème
donc je suis invité par par un ami c'est
un déplacement parfaitement touristique
et j'allais dire footballistique
dans ce cadre là il me dit écoute on a
la possibilité de rencontrer Thierry
Mariani lors d'une réunion et se
présenterait un ami qui est qui est
également chef d'entreprise russe
voilà c'est dans ces conditions là que
je rencontre Monsieur mallof
dans une conversation qui est d'ailleurs
très banale où on parle de la situation
en France
je remets des choses en place aussi d'un
point de vue du contexte nous sommes
dans la France de 2018 monsieur Macron
vient d'être élu et le président Macron
a invité Vladimir Poutine au château de
Versailles la Russie n'est pas du tout
pestiféré la Russie n'est pas du tout
considéré comme un ennemi de la France
et j'allais dire toute la France se
retrouve à la Coupe du monde
et donc c'est à l'occasion et je me dis
tiens je vais rencontrer Mariani puisque
il est question que Mariani
intègre la liste des européennes puisque
il avait fait un certain nombre de
signaux qui étaient convergents et qui
permettait de penser que il pouvait être
nous rejoindre et nous rallier je
précise également que c'est important
parce que
en 2017 le parti Front national est
totalement défait on sort de l'élection
présidentielle et surtout législative
avec si malheureux députés qui se
battent mais qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
pouvoir on n'a pas de visibilité on est
un petit peu effondré on est en pleine
refondation et donc on est un parti qui
qui est heureux de se refaire notamment
par le biais de de ralliement un petit
peu de visibilité politique en France
c'est dans ce cadre là que je rencontre
Mariani on va à une réception de
rencontre il y a un certain nombre de
gens je ne pourrais même pas vous citer
de mémoire les noms qui étaient parce
que je ne sais je ne sais pas
vous allez une réception et un certain
nombre de gens certains prennent la
parole mais je ne peux pas les citer je
pourrais pas en citer trois et donc
voilà que fait la connaissance de
Thierry meradiqui et par la suite
deviendra un ami et nous rejoindra sur
la liste et siège avec moi au groupe au
groupe quant à Monsieur malfraise je ne
le connais pas je dis ok contact avec
lui avant je le rencontre on a une
discussion d'une demi-heure on parle de
choses et d'autres et notamment la
situation française il me fait part de
de son inquiétude de voir notamment la
situation
liée à la question migratoire en France
et puis voilà on a cette réunion mais je
n'ai pas d'autres contacts avec lui
après une fois que vous avez été invité
quelque part vous envoyer un message je
pense que ça vous arrive
madame la rapporteur d'envoyer un
message de remerciement pour dire que
vous avez passé un bon moment avec les
invités voilà il y a pas de choses
particulières mais évidemment pour moi
la question qui était essentielle
c'était de rencontrer Thierry Maryse ce
qui paraît un petit peu bizarre de
rencontrer en Russie mais je n'avais pas
eu l'occasion de le rencontrer en France
pardonnez-moi de le montrer un tout
petit peu insistante j'entends très bien
que la courtoisie
dont notre pays sonore n'est-ce pas dans
les relations avec les uns et des autres
amènent à remercier de l'accueil et
d'une possibilité de rencontre mais dans
le mail encore une fois que dossier
Center a transmis un nombre de de
journalistes
il y a un peu plus que des remerciements
extrêmement courtois pour à la qualité
d'un accueil la gentillesse d'une
réception etc puisqu'il y a clairement
quelque chose s'agissant
encore une fois ce que vous décrivez
comme des belles rencontres qui auraient
une utilité décisive pour les prochaines
élections européennes et nous allons
maintenant j'ouvre encore une fois les
guillemets travailler notre côté à leur
donner tous les développements dont la
cause a besoin donc on est un peu
au-delà de du mail de remerciement et
donc simplement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer que avec Monsieur
balofiev la conversion a porté également
sur des sujets politiques et par exemple
sur un projet de de mise en réseau de de
rassemblement d'ensemble de famille
politique de droite extrême et d'extrême
droite avec un centre de valeurs et de
et de positionnement politique comme un
tout d'abord quand vous parlez de droite
extrême et d'extrême droite ne sont pas
concernés donc en ce qui concerne le
reste non il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu
de propositions de d'accéder à quoi que
ce soit moi je suis je suis même pas élu
alors maintenant que les gens étaient
plutôt favorables à la philosophie
politique que j'ai fait en oui il y
avait pas d'insoumis il y avait pas de
communiste bien sûr mais pour autant
c'était pas comment dire c'était une
rencontre parfaitement
courtoise et amicale et pas du tout
un centre de décision d'un complot
mondial
personne ici n'a employé ce genre
d'expression est-ce que vous pouvez
juste
pardon excusez-moi ici c'est les membres
de la commission d'enquête qui posent
des questions et la parole est
distribuer par Monsieur le Président
nous fonctionnons en tandem comme je
fonctionne habituellement avec le
président Tanguy dans notamment la
répartition de de la parole
du coup effectivement
vous
[Musique]
estimez je reprends pas du tout
l'expression que vous avez utilisé mais
qu'il n'y a pas eu la mort c'est d'un
commencement de
suite donner à cette à cette rencontre
est-ce que vous pouvez juste nous
rappeler parce que vous nous avez dit
que vous n'aviez pas vous n'étiez pas
élu à l'époque quels étaient vos
fonctions au sein du rassemblement
national à ce moment-là
je n'en avais aucune j'étais assistant
parlementaire de Ludovico
je n'avais aucune fonction au sein du
rassemblement du Front national à
l'époque
vous avez terminé
et donc quand que ce soit complément
d'enquête ou beaucoup d'autres enquêtes
journalistiques et aussi d'ailleurs le
dossier élaboré par l'ONG basé à Londres
dossier Center fait allusion à ce projet
halte interne ou au projet de
Sainte-Alliance ça ne vous dit rien du
tout vous n'avez jamais entendu parler
écoutez si vous vous renseignez sur moi
vous verrez que je suis plutôt à laïc et
appartenir à un projet de Saint alliance
me semble un petit peu curieux donc non
j'en profite pour rebondir donc
pouvez-vous nous affirmer que nous
faisiez pas partie vous ne vous êtes pas
rapproché de ce projet all interne
non
je n'ai rien signé je n'ai rien je suis
même pas au courant de ce projet
d'accord donc pour vous c'est pas il
s'agissait pas de la cause commune dont
vous aviez besoin
mob à cause aussi nationale et donc je
défends les nations et quand je
rencontre d'autres patriotes même s'ils
sont lointains j'estime avoir une cause
commune avec elle ça ne fait pas de moi
des agents de ces pays
une cause européenne sans doute aussi
oui ça dépend ce qu'on entend dans la
conception de l'Europe on pourra en
parler mais ce serait un peu
merci je vais laisser la parole au
commissaire qui veulent bien s'exprimer
c'est des personnes sont inscrites
monsieur Dumont
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Olivier bonjour
alors pour la bonne compréhension tous
je tiens à préciser qu'on avait été
adversaire politique sur deux élections
à la fois les élections législatives de
2017 et les élections cantonales dans le
canton de marque en 2021 pour que les
choses soient claires et qui est pas de
pas de problème après qu'on puisse pas
reprocher quoi que ce soit je voudrais
revenir tout d'abord monsieur le député
européen
sur les ce qui a été évoqué par madame
le rapporteur alors je sais pas qu'on
voulait qu'on fonctionne monsieur le
Président est-ce que je peux poser
plusieurs questions réponses je poste
d'un coup si c'est pas trop de questions
à la fois faut en poser plusieurs sinon
il faudra peut-être attendre la réponse
pour revenir sur ce que vient poser
comme question madame le rapporteur
madame le rapporteur a fait état d'un
email qui a été liqué en mauvais
français par un organisme non étatique
qui expliquait que vous en effet vous je
le lis vous voulez remercier votre hotte
de l'accueil et de la gentillesse
toujours par rapport à la Coupe du monde
en Russie en 2018 il voulait transmettre
à Constantin donc on a parlé le
témoignage de la gratitude pour les
moments amicaux utiles s'agissant d'une
finale de Coupe du Monde de la France a
gagné inoubliable alors est-ce que vous
reconnaissez ça va renvoyer cette email
bien sûr
je ne dis pas le contraire je n'en sais
rien
généralement quand je suis invité un
dîner à un repas à n'importe quel
invitation j'envoie un mail assez
courtois je dois dire de remerciements
donc j'ai dû le faire parce que je le
fais de manière mécanique pour toutes
les occasions
et évidemment tout à votre honneur la
politesse se perd régulièrement à notre
pays en tout cas je le note
donc vous faites référence à un
Constantin donc vous confirmez que le
Constantin auquel vous faites référence
dans cet email et bien le fameux
Constantin FF auquel nous faisons
référence depuis beaucoup d'auditions
dans cette commission d'enquête
expliquer dans quelles conditions je
l'ai rencontré
en particulier c'était très rapide enfin
ça a été dû être une demi-heure on a
pris un pot ensemble voilà je ne le
connais pas plus je n'ai pas eu de de
contact avec lui avant et je n'ai pas eu
de contact avec lui après
très bien je fais du mot pardon je vous
remercie et
donc vous confirmez que
ce fameux Constantin on a eu absolument
rien à voir
de près ou de loin dans votre présence
par exemple dans le stade je crois que
c'est le stade lounge Niki si je dis pas
de bêtises pour la finale de la Coupe du
monde et qui n'avait absolument rien à
voir avec votre présence dans le stade
je n'en sais rien moi en tout cas je
n'ai pas du tout eu en ligne ou pas
quelques mois que ce soit monsieur
Constantin mal aux fèves c'est mon ami
français qui m'a qui m'a invité qui
était la puissance à 8 ans pour moi
très bien je vous remercie deux
dernières questions
vous étiez membre de l'équipe resserrée
de campagne de Madame Le Pen lors des
élections présidentielles de 2022 il
avait été fait état d'une potentielle
destruction de tracts édité par les
fraises de votre partie ou figuré une
photo de votre candidate avec le
président de la Fédération de Russie
probablement pour montrer une satur
internationale est-ce que vous confirmez
la destruction de tract qui sont sortis
des presses de votre partie comme ça pu
être fait état par la presse
faudrait bien répondre aux questions
mais je ne m'en souviens pas
vous savez dans les campagnes
électorales enfin je m'occupe pas
forcément des tracts je m'occupe plutôt
des des stratégies des concepts
politiques et donc je m'occupe pas
forcément du tract
je lui demande une autre question
dernière question
si nous regardons votre fiche sur le
site du Parlement européen nous pouvons
noter que durant la liste de vos
assistants accrédités figurent une
personne qui est Irina to Makina
et qui d'après le site projet Arcadie
présente un profil qui est un peu
compliqué à trouver est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer d'où vient cette
personne comment vous l'avez recruté qui
vous l'a présenté bref quel est le
processus de recrutement quelle est sa
nationalité et quel est le travail
effectif qu'elle fait à votre service
alors quand il y a eu les élections de
législatives il se trouve que
pratiquement tous mes assistants étaient
élus soit ils ont été élus députés et
sièges ici soit ils sont montés comme
députés européens et je les ai perdu
comme assistance j'ai donc été obligé
dans catastrophe de retrouver des
assistants le travail parlementaire
européen est une chose mais il y a un
travail administratif autour du travail
parlementaire notamment pour tous les
voyages et comme on dit amené à beaucoup
se déplacer alors moi je fais pas
beaucoup de voyages mais je fais quand
même des déplacements Paris-Bruxelles
Paris Strasbourg etc il faut quelqu'un
pour s'occuper de ça je me suis retrouvé
donc sans assistant et j'étais obligé de
prendre un assistant de remplacement qui
est cette personne dont vous fait état
Irina c'est quelqu'un qui travaillait
pour un député de la Ligue 1
et qui connaissait parfaitement le
mécanisme de fonctionnement de
remboursement des frais elle part je
l'ai pris pour 6 mois uniquement pour
faire la le tampon et pour pouvoir elle
quitte la ses fonctions puisque je
renouvelle pas sur mandat alors sur sa
nationalité la réalité de nationalité
russe la réalité c'est que elle est
ukrainienne elle est née en Ukraine non
pas d'ailleurs l'Ukraine côté côté russe
oriental mais côté occidental et donc
c'est lui faire un mauvais procès que de
penser qu'elle puisse y avoir un
problème il y a tellement peu de
problèmes d'ailleurs c'est que quand
elle a quand j'ai émis le souhait de la
l'embaucher le Parlement européen a fait
une enquête ce qui est tout à fait
normal et bon moi je ne la connaissais
pas plus que ça elle avait un bon CV
elle connaissait le travail et c'était
ce dont j'avais besoin pour pour
l'imedia et il y a eu quatre mois
d'enquête du Parlement européen
et au bout de ces quatre points
d'enquête le Parlement européen a donné
son accord donc moi je suis pas plus
royaliste que le roi c'était pour six
mois et cela remplace là par une par une
par une autre assistante que j'ai eu le
temps de former en attendant
absolument vous avez terminé merci je
vais passer la parole à mon collègue
seasentool
micro monsieur le député
merci monsieur le Président alors j'ai
aussi plusieurs petites questions je les
je l'ai posé d'une après les autres
comme mon collègue du Mans je pense que
c'est plus simple pour la compréhension
collective la première en revenant donc
à votre voyage à l'été 2018 en Russie
alors
d'être pas certain où vous avez un peu
oublié les contacts que vous avez pu
avoir directement indirectement avec
Monsieur maloufev contact en revanche
vous avez beaucoup cité ce fameux amis
français donc est-ce qu'on pourrait
savoir qui est cet ami français
donc quel contexte il vous a invité
comment était organisé ce voyage qu'il a
financé et quelle est l'activité de
cette personne
alors c'est quelqu'un que je connais qui
s'appelle Fabrice Orlin quelqu'un que je
connais depuis 20 ans que je revois
régulièrement et qui est installé en
Russie depuis près une quinzaine
d'années quelque chose comme ça voilà et
c'est ce qu'il a une entreprise et que
il est installé en Russie
dans son activité professionnelle sur
place je pourrais pas vous la citer
qui a financé ce voyage
c'est lui qui s'est occupé du voyage je
suppose que que enfin moi je suppose que
c'est lui je
nous ai voyagé en classe eco
à l'époque je vous rappelle que j'étais
simplement citoyen j'avais pas de raison
de déclarer le voyage je n'avais pas de
pouvoir d'ailleurs est-ce qu'un député a
des a des secrets d'État je n'en sais
rien et encore moins un assistant et
encore moins un assistant d'opposition
et d'oppositionne non inscrits c'est à
dire qu'on avait accès à rien donc
j'étais pas en soi une cible quelconque
merci pour ces premiers réponses alors
la deuxième question bon je trouve que
vous
vous faites quand même peu de cas de la
position que vous aviez déjà à cette
époque au sein du Front National et
auprès de sa présidente et d'ailleurs
moi je tiens à vous poser cette deuxième
question pour que quand même tout ça
soit très clair parce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que vous n'aviez
aucune fonction
en quelques secondes sur les moteurs de
recherche on trouve qu'en 2018 certes
vous n'aviez plus de mandat électif que
vous alliez retrouver un an plus tard
lors des élections européennes mais que
vous aviez bien des fonctions politiques
puisqu'il semble que vous soyez rentré
au bureau national du Front national
désigné copier je sais pas comment on
dit dans le langage de ce parti par la
présidente Marine Le Pen elle-même lors
du congrès de mars 2018 donc est-ce que
vous étiez bien à partir de mars 2018
membre du bureau national du Front
National et donc on peut considérer que
que vous aviez une fonction
partisane donc politique oui je vais
panier que j'avais
engagé politiquement maintenant avoir
une fonction j'ai aucun pouvoir un
membre du bureau national n'a aucun
pouvoir dans le parti
c'est pas ça je n'étais pas dans le
parti politique le bureau national c'est
car à l'époque 40 ou 50 membres qu'ils
se réunissent une fois par mois pour
parler des affaires politiques c'est
simplement une
instance absolument sans pouvoir
déterminant
et je n'ai pas de fonction je suis pas
directeur de service je ne suis pas
secrétaire général je n'ai pas de
fonction opérationnelle au sein du parti
alors bien sûr que c'est un secret de
polichinelle je suis le conseiller de
Marine Le Pen mais je suis un conseiller
[Musique]
de manière historique depuis 2005 voilà
mais ça n'interfère pas du tout dans
dans le travail que je peux avoir qu'à
l'époque le travail d'assistant
même si je m'occupe évidemment d'action
politique mais je n'ai pas de pouvoir
opérationnel
je vous remercie pour ces précisions
mais qui du coup pour moi viennent en
fait contredire ce que vous avez dit
dans votre induction introduction et
répondu et répondu aux premières
questions du du président et la
rapporteur c'est à dire de choses l'une
soit vous êtes un simple citoyen mais
dans ce cas là vous n'avez pas
d'engagement politique on conseille pas
un président de parti enfin je veux dire
ici on fait tous la politique depuis
certaines années on connaît les parties
enfin on devient pas proche conseiller
d'un président de parti fut-il de
l'opposition en étant un simple un
simple citoyen et on ne rentre pas dans
le bureau national d'un parti quand même
important comme les Front national
depuis plusieurs plusieurs années
inopiné comme ça du jour au lendemain
donc voilà le récit qui a été le vôtre
au début de cette position de dire je
suis un simple citoyen et puis j'ai
simplement fait de voyage en Russie
honnêtement moi je vous le dis j'ai du
mal à la j'ai du mal à l'accepter
qui plus est à partir de 2018 quand vous
vous rendez pour pour la Coupe du Monde
et pouvoir d'autres personnes lors de ce
voyage en Russie vous êtes proche
conseiller de Marine Le Pen Marine Le
Pen a été au second tour l'élection
présidentielle elle a été reçue je le
rappelle un mois avant le scrutin du
premier tour la présidentielle de 2017
ces liens et son admiration pour
Vladimir Poutine son notoire donc peut
pas considérer vous êtes un simple
français parmi les 66 millions de
Français qui avaient à l'époque qui vous
rendez comme ça et en plus vous ne
l'avez pas nié vous avez rencontré quand
même des personnes qui sont plus ou
moins dans la galaxie dans la galaxie
des dirigeants russes voilà donc je
pense que
je veux dire quand je suis un simple
citoyen j'ai aucune fonction publique je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas de mandat je n'ai
pouvoir je n'ai pouvoir sur rien je n'ai
accès à rien je n'ai pas du tout de de
capacité ni d'action ni d'interaction en
quoi que ce soit
j'y vais d'ailleurs de manière
personnelle
j'y reviens de manière personnelle alors
après le deuxième voyage je le fais en
tant que parlementaire et je vous ai dit
je n'ai pas caché j'ai tellement peu
caché que j'ai fait ma déclaration
exactement dans les temps alors que un
certain nombre de députés
la font pour en rattrapage moi je l'ai
fait dans les temps parce que je n'ai
absolument rien à cacher
en étant membre du bureau national je
peux vous dire qu'on a du rassemblement
national alors en l'occurrence
d'ailleurs vous dites c'est un grand
parti qui que etc oui aujourd'hui oui
mais à l'époque je vous rappelle qu'on
est totalement défait on ne se refait
finalement électoralement causes
élections européennes mais en 2018 on
est à partir qui n'a qui
dont on annonce la mort tous les jours
donc quand vous nous dites c'est un
grand parti qui est de l'influence etc
c'est une vision d'aujourd'hui c'est pas
la vision de l'époque quand vous nous
dites c'était la Russie un pays terrible
etc pas du tout c'était un pays que
Monsieur
que Monsieur Macron voulait attirer dans
dans le champ politique européen donc il
faut se remettre dans le contexte de
l'époque je crois que vous ne pouvez pas
raisonner
aujourd'hui comme nous résonnions en
au moment d'un événement comme la Coupe
du Monde ou l'équipe de France était en
finale et où il y avait une beaucoup de
Français énormément de français à Moscou
troisième
question on passe on avance un petit peu
donc on en arrive au second voyage que
vous affirmez faire en Russie mais on va
arriver du coup à la discussion donc le
premier juillet 2020
je cite des propos que vous écrivez sur
un réseau social bien connu je suis
actuellement à Yalta en Russie
j'insiste sur Yalta en Russie ou une
délégation de députés du groupe ID
observe le bon déroulement du référendum
constitutionnel organisé c'est moi qui
l'ajoute par par Moscou bien entendu
excellente participation du scrutin et
organisation exemplaire donc on se
remettant dans le contexte que l'époque
qu'elle vous nous appelez on rappelle
quand même que la Russie envahit
occupe illégalement contradiction avec
le droit international la Crimée depuis
2014 que c'est d'ailleurs la position
des deux présidents de la République
successifs François Hollande et Emmanuel
Macron de ne pas reconnaître
cette annexion est de blâmer et de
critiquer bien entendu la Fédération de
Russie et donc vous voilà il y a le
temps en Russie vous reconnaissez cette
annexion cette annexion illégale donc je
pense ça serait intéressant que vous
nous expliquez d'une certaine façon
cette forme un peu de déloyaux l'été
vis-à-vis de la position de la
diplomatie française
écoutez un élu c'est quelqu'un de libre
c'est quelqu'un qui a droit d'avoir des
opinions divergentes c'est en tout cas
ma conception de la démocratie de la
liberté je pense que ça doit pas être la
vôtre
j'ai été enrimé pour voir si c'était
effectivement un pays occupé comme vous
l'avez
occupé s'il vous plaît
ok continuez d'accord
faut voir si c'était un pays occupé et
j'ai pu me rendre compte que ce n'est
pas un pays occupé c'est tellement vrai
c'est que quand je suis rentré je me
suis dit mais quel exemple on pourrait
trouver c'est comme si quelqu'un avait
expliqué le Nord-Pas-de-Calais c'est
belge vous êtes dans le Pas-de-Calais
tout le monde est français évidemment
c'est belge en fait on vit dans l'idée
que parce que coûte chef ou je ne sais
qui a rattaché administrativement la
Crimée que c'est un territoire
ukrainien ce n'est pas un territoire
sociologiquement
ukrainien et le dire c'est pas en soi
c'est pas en soi hérétique je dirais en
plus que il y a eu un référendum le
référendum a été a été pour pour le
rattachement donc moi je j'ai le droit
d'avoir une opinion qui n'est peut-être
pas la vôtre mais j'ai le droit d'avoir
une opinion divergente
merci monsieur le député ma dernière
question je précise référendum non
reconnue bien entendu par par notre pays
et par l'Union européenne ma dernière et
quatrième question
il me semble alors j'en suis pas certain
du coup pour répondre que vous ayez été
interdit de territoire en Ukraine donc
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer ou pas
cette information et pourquoi est-ce que
l'État
ukrainien vous a interdit de territoire
alors j'ai été interdit territoire et
encore plus tous mes biens en Ukraine
ont été saisis ça tombait bien j'en
avais pas oui c'est une décision qui est
automatique à partir du moment où vous
avez mettez les pieds en Crimée donc
c'est une décision automatique mais j'ai
pour compléter ce que vous dites et pour
être tout à fait complet je vais même
été sanctionné par le Parlement européen
Parlement européen était au courant de
mon voyage puisque je vous l'ai dit je
l'ai déclaré de manière formelle
conformément au texte et j'ai été
sanctionné et on m'a reproché d'avoir
été
rassembler une élection
alors on m'a pas reproché le voyage on
m'a reproché d'avoir contrôlé une
élection et de ne pas avoir tiré les
conclusions que l'Union européenne
aurait voulu que je tire voilà ce qui
m'a été reproché et la sanction que j'ai
eu au Parlement européen c'est une
sanction qui est prise sur la base d'un
texte qui concerne pas les élus qui ont
jusqu'à présent une liberté de voyage je
pense en tout cas c'est la conception de
mon mandat mais les fonctionnaires du
Parlement européen qui ne peuvent pas
voyager donc cette décision de sanction
m'apparaît pas très fondée juridiquement
la conteste maintenant j'accepte et si
vous voulez c'était quand même un petit
peu indolore il faut bien le dire
merci vous avez terminé cher collègue
avant de passer la parole à Monsieur
Tanguy je vais laisser la part la
constance qui me l'avait demandé
précédemment c'est la parole même le
rapport
merci monsieur le Président oui
rapidement je voulais juste revenir sur
le profil de l'ami français qui vous a
invité à Moscou pour la finale de la
Coupe du monde de football vous nous
avez dit qu'il s'agit de Fabrice Sorlin
je prononce bien le mot il s'agit bien
de Fabrice Sorlin que vous connaissez ou
que vous connaissiez avez-vous dit
depuis une vingtaine d'années ça n'est
pas tout à fait un inconnu pour celles
et ceux je le dis pour les journalistes
et puis les éventuels internautes qui
qui regardent ces travaux qui auraient
l'occasion de les regarder en différé
pour qui s'intéresse un peu au réseau
russe je veux dire ça au sens large et
n'y voyait aucune vérité complotiste
dans ma bouche mais enfin c'est une
c'est une réalité
et donc si vous connaissiez depuis 20
ans Fabrice Sorlin vous ne pouviez pas
ignorer
ces positions politiques ces choix
politiques bien connus encore une fois
qui sont
tout à fait
légitime entre guillemets et ça n'est
pas de cela
dont il s'agit donc qui est connu pour
être un catholique traditionaliste avec
un centre de de position en matière
internationale et et de relations
étrangères bien connues et qui donc a
choisi effectivement de de s'installer à
Moscou et donc forcément les personnes
qu'il pouvait
vous amener à rencontrer lors de ce
séjour
pouvait
dans votre esprit je pense tout tout
naturellement
être de ça se sphère
ou de ou participer du même
je dirais entourage intellectuel et
politique voilà donc je pense que vous
ne pouviez pas de ne pas savoir quels
étaient les types de fréquentations
politiques avaient Fabrice Sorlin et
qu'elle était de ce fait peut-être les
dessins qui pouvaient vouloir servir ne
serait-ce qu'auprès des interlocuteurs
russes qui le
avait amené à vous faire rencontrer
encore une fois que ce soit monsieur
Malo fief ou d'autres dont vous n'avez
plus les noms en tête tout cela converge
quand même sur une certaine voilà je
dirais
école
intellectuelle et tout ça ne pouvait pas
à moins d'être extrêmement naïf être
totalement
ignoré de vous voilà c'était juste pour
l'éclairage des membres de cette
commission d'enquête
simplement pour vous dire que je ne suis
pas catholique intégriste ou
traditionaliste autre chose je vous
rassure tout de suite je n'ai pas de de
jugement apporté sur les opinions de mes
amis on a un certain nombre d'amis qui
n'ont pas exactement les mêmes positions
que moi pour autant je n'adhère pas
forcément à l'heure à leur choix
philosophique politique religieux etc et
je m'honore de ne pas leur en faire le
reproche
passe la parole au président Tanguy
communiqué à quelqu'un enfin en tout cas
comment on peut expliquer est-ce que
vous avez eu une information qui permet
d'expliquer que ce cet éclore
confidentiel comme malheureusement
d'ailleurs d'autres échanges
confidentielles on a pu parler lors de
nos travaux de tes Macron X et puis être
sortir de du cadre de la confidentialité
absolument pas je n'ai pas été du tout
informé de quoi que ce soit chez lui ça
dans la presse j'ai traité ça par un
haussement d'épaule pour tout vous dire
et pour être très franc
ça
ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup c'est un
mail le remerciement
qui semble être une pièce décisive vous
remercier les gens de manière assez
convenu
d'une rencontre
je dois dire que mon
téléphone ou mon
système d'ordinateur a également été en
vedette dans l'affaire du du Maroc
puisque j'ai lu dans la presse que les
Marocains m'écoutaient etc là aussi j'ai
traité ça par le haussement d'épaule
mais non je n'ai pas été informé du tout
d'une d'un quelconque piratage
une autre question oui merci Monsieur
président ma deuxième question vous avez
fait mention
un moment Monsieur Philippe Olivier au
sujet donc de ce projet
alterne pardon donc de d'organisation
des droites extrêmes et l'extrême droite
comme le rapporteur sur une ligne nos
auditions l'ont montré une ligne
effectivement de forme de nouvelles
satalliance a été souligné par un
certain nombre d'experts ou de en tout
cas d'alliance de courant qui estiment
qu'il y a un problème d'ordre moral de
perte de valeur traditionaliste et que
c'est une des ça explique ça
expliquerait la pseudo décadence des
démocraties européennes et américaine ce
qui peut faire rire quand on voit l'état
de la société russe par rapport à l'état
de la société française ne serait-ce que
sur l'espérance de vie mais passons sur
ce commentaire personnel sur ce qui
était toi vous avez dit à au détour de
de vos explications que vous étiez à
laïc et effectivement ces travaux ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a étonné j'aimerais avoir
votre réflexion là-dessus et peut-être
ce qui peut éclairer les échanges que
vous avez eu avec Monsieur
[Musique]
non mais j'y vais un ami ma vie privée
au hasard d'une invitation on rencontre
des gens moi je venais je vous l'ai dit
pour Thierry Mariani vous ne vous vous
m'accorderez que tu
n'es pas un ayatollah c'est quelqu'un de
tout à fait tout à fait laïque et tout à
fait respectueux des principes
[Musique]
républicains voilà il y a pas il y a pas
de de comment dire
chez Thierry Mariani comme chez moi de
vision religieuse du tout et je suis
d'accord avec vous on ne serait pas les
les bons agents de ce type d'alliance
pas du tout du tout si vous reprenez
d'ailleurs
mais tweets tous mes propos politiques
et je vous invite à le faire vous vous
ne verrez pas
de tweets
qui ne condamne pas le l'agression russe
qui me tient tout à fait à la position
qui est celle qui est la mienne et celle
de mon mouvement sur sur l'agression
russe donc je ne je ne
relais absolument
aucune influence étrangère d'aucune
sorte et encore moins d'influence
religieuse donc une sorte je suis un
laïc je vous ai dit que j'ai travaillé
auprès de de Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen
a été celle qui a remise qui a remis la
laïcité au cœur du débat français
pour tout vous dire c'était assez coté à
travailler sur cette question là je vois
pas pourquoi je travaillerai à un ordre
religieux quel qu'il soit tout ça et
m'apparaît tout à fait artificiel
merci monsieur le Président une dernière
question que je veux pas monopoliser
évidemment la parole ma dernière
question c'est que comme la souligner
Charles vous êtes vous avez aussi
travaillé sur la campagne présidentielle
une fois plus en transparence nous
travaillons ensemble d'ailleurs pour
informer la Commission parce que moi
laissez tous dur d'apporter les
informations dont j'ai aussi en ma
possession pour éclairer nos débats la
question qui a été posée sur libération
ce que je peux donner à l'information là
dessus ou pas
c'est en fait une fausse information de
libération c'est moi qui m'occupais des
tracts pendant la campagne je n'ai
jamais demandé la destruction de ces
tracts et je tiens à disposition de la
rapporteur les échanges que j'ai vu avec
libération à l'époque si vous le
souhaitez le sur le
sur le le pas dans le sujet vous voulez
revenir voilà ce qui est aussi
intéressant dans dans puisque vous avez
été convoqué par par notre commission
c'est aussi sans doute le regard que
vous avez vu sur la dernière élection
présidentielle puisque le plusieurs
questions d'une part c'était la
motivation de de cette commission est-ce
que vous de votre poste d'observateur
aussi de responsable politique que vous
avez il vous semble que le problème des
ingérences étrangères des tentatives ou
des ingérences avérées étrangères à
poser question lors de la dernière
présidentielle dans le paysage politique
français et est-ce que vous en tant que
membre de l'équipe de campagne
présidentielle vous avez assisté à des
décisions des réflexions qui pouvaient
traduire une forme d'intérence étrangère
ou au contraire des décisions qui
étaient prises selon
la doctrine de l'équipe de campagne qui
était autonome de toute influence
étrangère
nous nous sommes des patriotes français
et tout notre
tout notre grille de lecture
par de d'une question simple quel est
l'intérêt de la France il y a pas
d'autres sujets qui nous intéressent et
il n'y a pas d'autres influent que que
cette que la réponse à cette question là
donc on est très loin de toutes les
influences étrangères il n'y a
évidemment aucune influence étrangère
sur notre réflexion politique il ne peut
pas y en avoir parce que par définition
nous sommes des partisans de la nation
française il a souveraineté française
donc il n'y a aucune
tentative
enfin moi je n'ai constaté aucune
tentative et de toute façon toutes les
tentatives seraient vouées à l'échec
puisque par nature par essence notre
combat et le combat d'une France
souveraine
merci monsieur
le rapporteur
micro
ce que vous venez de dire monsieur le
député
il y a néanmoins s'agissant du sujet des
influences interférences ingérence qui
est celui qui intéresse la commission
d'enquête
assemble de choses qu'il nous faut
rappeler et notamment
même si encore une fois le pyralisme
politique dans notre pays à toute sa
place bien évidemment mais il y a des
déplacements répétés de dirigeants du
Front national puis du rassemblement
national en Russie des votent répétés
au Parlement européen sur de très
nombreuses
résolutions
soutenant
l'Ukraine ou voilà ou soutenant et à
plan au renforcement des sanctions
contre
la Russie sur lesquels les députés
européens du rassemblement national
n'ont pas eu par exemple les mêmes votes
que ceux d'autres groupes qui composent
la voilà le bloc central au sein au sein
du Parlement européen et donc la
majorité au sein du Parlement européen
des déclarations extrêmement
appuyées de Madame Le Pen en verre
Vladimir Poutine et d'autres dirigeants
de haut niveau du du rassemblement
national donc tout cela
incline quand même à penser que il y a
eu à tout le moins
de très très fortes convergence de vue
sur beaucoup beaucoup de sujets très
régulièrement et spectaculairement mise
en scène y compris à un mois du premier
tour je crois de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 donc
j'entends bien ce que vous dites sur le
patriotisme mais voilà il faut quand
même rappeler et je pense que il est
important que nos concitoyens le sachent
en soi pleinement conscient qui qu'il y
a eu des à tout le moins
complaisance appuyé qui sont allés
jusqu'à encore une fois peut-être c'est
un autre sujet et d'ailleurs je voulais
vous interroger à ce à ce sujet
un financement à travers des prêts
pendant
la campagne présidentielle de Madame Le
Pen et je voulais d'ailleurs vous
interroger à ce sujet est-ce que vous
avez de près ou de loin été amené à
connaître des des
tentatives de recherche de financement
de la campagne présidentielle de Madame
Le Pen
alors je ferai un commentaire quand même
sur votre observation avant de répondre
si vous me permettez
alors
novotes novottes ne sont absolument pas
honteux nos votes libres qui décide en
fonction de critères qu'ils estiment
qu'ils estiment légitimes en
l'occurrence les critères qui qui font
de nos votes je vous l'ai dit c'est
l'intérêt national
nous avons refusé des aides à l'Ukraine
au moment où l'Ukraine était
sous le coup d'accusation de la Cour
européenne la Cour des comptes
européennes pour son niveau de
corruption
à partir de l'invasion russe nous avons
condamné évidemment l'invasion russe et
nous avons
comment dire
réfléchi à l'histoire des sanctions qui
était une question évidemment
fondamentale on est absolument pas
contre les fonctions on a été contre des
sanctions qui pouvaient attenter à
l'intérêt économique de nos pays et
notamment des sanctions énergétiques
irréfléchies parce qu'il nous apparaît
que
avant de prendre des décisions de guerre
énergétique il faut être sûr de pouvoir
les gagner en non seulement on l'a pas
gagné on l'a perdu mais on n'a pas
j'allais dire comment dire créer un
quelconque préjudice pour pour la Russie
un préjudice financier ou un préjudice
d'influence au contraire donc notre
guerre énergétique ne s'est pas avéré
très payante je pense qu'on avait une
position et qu'on a une position
extrêmement
ferme en ce qui concerne la l'agression
russe mais tout à fait réfléchi sur
l'efficacité des sanctions il faut des
sanctions mais des sanctions efficaces
maintenant s'agissant des du pré russe
qui est après totalement
usuraire qui était à un taux phénoménal
qui n'est pas celui d'un
d'une banque ami contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu lire
ce n'est pas des questions dont je
m'occupe je m'occupe absolument pas de
financement maintenant le pré russe je
peux vous le garantir n'était pas prêt
d'amis c'était un prêt extrêmement dur
pour le pour le débiteur que nous étions
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler
quels sont les fonctions que vous
occupez actuellement si vous en occupez
dans l'organigramme du rassemblement
national
aujourd'hui je suis
donc je suis député européen
et je suis membre du bureau du de la
délégation française au Parlement
européen voilà pour l'aspect
parlementaire et je suis membre du
bureau exécutif du du rassemblement
national le Bureau Exécutif étant
l'instance de direction des
10 ou 12
responsables du parti
je n'ai pas de fonction opérationnelle
au sein du parti
pas de fonction opérationnelles pas les
responsabilités opérationnelles mais
notamment votre qualité de membres du
Parlement européen
vous êtes plutôt considéré comme un
conseiller sur les sujets européens et
ou internationaux pourrait-on dire pour
la celle qui fut longtemps la présidente
du rassemblement et peut-être toujours
pour l'actuel président
non je vais vous surprendre peut-être
mais je suis de conseil Marine Le Pen
sur un certain nombre de suffit et sur
la question internationale européenne
c'est une ce sont d'autres cellules qui
s'occupent de cela donc moi je m'occupe
pas forcément évidemment je peux lui
donner mon avis en tant que député
européen et je ne suis pas du tout
spécialiste des questions
internationales mais pas du tout donc je
m'intéresse plutôt aux questions
de fond question politique au grand
débat etc ou aux stratégies mais pas du
tout à l'action internationale qui est
un domaine que je ne connais pas
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Olivier j'ai une dernière question à
vous poser en revenant à la campagne
présidentielle de 2017
puisque
il a été établi de façon quasi certaine
ça nous a d'ailleurs été confirmé
lors de certaines auditions d'ailleurs
les comptes-rendus sont déjà public que
il n'est quasiment certain que que la
Russie a essayé de déstabiliser
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
en défaveur du président de la
République actuelle et candidats de
l'époque Emmanuel Macron que vous
inspire ce fait qui aujourd'hui est
documenté de
façon quasi quasi certaine voilà par les
propres services de l'État français
je n'ai pas d'opinion sur la question
s'il y a une ingérence étrangère je la
condamne mais je n'ai pas d'informations
particulières sur la question on ne peut
pas vous répondre
évidemment étant patriotes toutes les
interférences étrangères d'où qu'elles
viennent quelque soit le pays y compris
le pays admis ou faux amis
je m'oppose à cela et donc évidemment je
le condamne mais je n'ai pas sur le
sujet sur le dossier que vous vous
évoquez d'informations particulières
j'ai terminé
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
voudrais poser une dernière question
j'aimerais revenir sur sur le feu mail
qui a été un peu le fil conducteur de
nos échanges et vous n'avez pas tout à
fait répandu tout à l'heure au sujet des
belles rencontres vous parliez donc à ce
fameux Mirail ou Michael
rencontre nous avons pu faire grâce à
vous qui seront d'une utilité décisive
pour les prochaines élections je voulais
savoir de quelle rencontre il s'agit de
qui s'agit-il pouvez-vous nous citer des
noms et en quoi celle-ci pouvait être
décisive pour les élections européennes
merci je crois avoir répondu à cette
question j'ai le président
pour tout dire j'arrive dans une réunion
enfin une réception où je ne connais
personne
voilà et donc je remercie de manière
semble-t-il très courtoises j'étais
plutôt venu pour rencontrer Mariani que
je ne connaissais pas je vous l'ai dit
et aujourd'hui je ne pourrais pas citer
trois noms de gens qui étaient dans
cette dans cette réunion
je
il y a eu il y a pas eu d'avant il y a
pas eu d'après vous rentrez dans une
dans un endroit où il y a une quinzaine
une vingtaine de personnes voilà non je
peux pas vous citer de nom parce que je
ne les ai pas en tête
des gens qui me sont inconnus que je
n'ai pas noté j'étais dans un voyage qui
était plutôt un voyage touristique et je
vous l'ai dit plutôt footballistique
alors évidemment vous prêtez à ce voyage
des intentions absolument qui
m'apparaissent extravagante de
complots de choses de grands trucs
international etc mais il y a rien de
tout ça
je suis désolé de vous le dire ce mail
d'un mail de remerciement comme j'en
envoie un certain nombre j'ai plutôt une
plume ou j'aime bien écrire et peut-être
que je m'écoute écrire peut-être aussi
mais je
j'essaye d'être courtois dans mes dans
mes échanges épistolaires
d'accord ok mais votre pourtant ce mail
a l'air c'est quand même assez explicite
il me semble vous parler de belles
rencontres et donc bien des gens que
vous avez lequel vous avez discuté ou
que vous avez que vous avez comment dire
remarqué et
également le fait que je perds les
lunettes je suis pas perdu et le fait
que vous dites qu'il y a une utilité
décisive donc on voit bien qu'il y a un
lien entre ces belles rencontres c'était
unité décisive je vois pas comment c'est
possible que vous ne vous rappeliez même
pas de qui s'agit bah écoutez c'est
pourtant la vérité je vous ai dit que la
l'intérêt principal que j'avais de cette
réunion que je tirais de cette réunion
c'est les rapports amicaux que je vais
noué avec Thierry Mariani qui a ensuite
accepté de venir sur notre liste
pour le reste je ne connaissais pas les
gens je n'ai pas eu alors après ce sont
des gens qui nous étaient pas hostiles
politiquement évidemment mais quand vous
si vous allez dans une réception et que
vous parlez à trois ou quatre personnes
et que vous dites à la maîtresse de
maison j'ai rencontré j'ai fait de très
belles rencontres ça vous lit pas pour
la vie avec ces gens-là moi je n'ai eu
aucun contact avec aucune de ces
personnes mis à partir il Mariani après
après cet événement aucune ni avant ni
après donc je suis six ans après vous
vous admettrez que je n'ai plus
je peux ne pas me souvenir des noms de
ces personnes
merci monsieur le député je propose que
nous l'avions la séance
pardon madame la rapporteur une dernière
question
oui je voulais savoir j'avoue de pas
avoir consulté le site du Parlement
européen et la liste de vos déplacements
mais je voulais savoir si vous aviez eu
l'occasion d'effectuer des missions
d'observation électorales d'autres
scrutins et si oui
dans quel autre pays
non madame parce que comme je vous l'ai
dit j'ai été sanctionné par le Parlement
européen je n'ai plus droit d'aller
vérifier les élections
avant je n'en ai fait aucune mais j'ai
pas eu le temps d'en faire et maintenant
je n'ai plus droit alors comme je vous
l'ai dit c'est un peu indolore parce que
je n'imagine pas que le travail du d'un
parlementaire européen dans la France
actuelle ce soit d'aller
vérifier les le bon déroulement des
élections dans le monde
merci monsieur le député vous remercier
effectivement pour cet échange et puis
je vous propose de lever maintenant la
séance